Hi everyone, I hope
everybody is doing well.
I do have another lecture
presentation to give you all.
So I know you already
had a few, you had
a few ortho lectures,
and now we have a
few DPR lectures we're
gonna go through.
Today is gonna be a
great presentation.
I'm gonna be talking
about the history and
the physical exam of
the hip and the knee.
And so if any of you
all have any questions
for me at any time, here
is my email address.
Feel free to email me if
you have any questions
about the lectures or
sports medicine or anything
in general, I'm happy
to answer any questions.
So what we'll do is
we'll go straight
on to the lecture presentation.
This is a very important
presentation because at some
point everybody experienced
some kind of hip or
knee pain. Some of you all
may have some hip or knee
pain in the past yourself.
So we're going to learn
how to do a history taking
and a physical exam and
we're going to learn how
to evaluate the subjective
and the objective finding
relating to the examination
of the hip and the knee
uh we're going to talk
about some normal versus
abnormal findings all right
we're going to compare the
two and what is normal and
what is abnormal and we're
going to talk about ways
to document because when
we document we've got to
document in an appropriate
way so that whoever's
reading our note is going
to know exactly what we saw
and what we examined and
when the patient was seen
in the office uh hello
to the red wolf down in
Joanville and hello to Long
Island old Westbury campus.
We're going to start
out with the Jeopardy
game. So today's
Jeopardy category.
Well first of all
we can't have a
Jeopardy game unless
we have contestants.
So it's an honor to
introduce the two contestants
that we have both of
them being fourth years.
Our first contestant is
coming from Long Island
New York and she She
recently matched into
ophthalmology down at Downstate
in Brooklyn, New York.
All right, so Maria Canellos,
welcome to the game.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you for joining
us. And from Flushing,
Queens, New York, just
matched into her urology
residency, right,
over at Albany Medical
College, is Cindy Lin.
Thank you for having
me, too. Thank you for
joining us. So, one
interesting fact about both of
these contestants, they
were friends since first
year of medical school,
right? They started
medical school in 2020
during the COVID pandemic,
and that's when every
group had to be the same,
whether you were in DPR,
CBL, OMM, or anatomy,
right? So they were in the
same group, and they became
good friends throughout
medical school, and they're
both very, very successful
in the mass season. And
another cool fact is that they
both rotated with me during
slot number 8 during our
sports medicine rotation.
And there's a lot
of sports medicine
coverage and we'll talk
about that later on.
So without any
further delay, we
will get started with the game.
So we'll have
Maria, you get the
honor of picking
the first category.
Great, thank you.
Sherlock Holmes, investigating
the pain for 300, please.
You got it. And once
you guys know the
answer, feel free
to raise your hand.
The categories are Hip
Hip Hooray, All About Me,
meaning every answer is
going to begin with ME.
Just like everyone,
every medical student, we
all have the need to
succeed, special testing,
and Sherlock Holmes
investigating the pain. So
we'll begin with Sherlock
Holmes investigating
the pain for $300.
The health history
revealed that the pain
is not localized.
Rather, the pain is this.
Uh, Cindy, you had
your hand up first.
What is diffused pain?
That is correct.
That is what is diffused
pain. You can also
say what is generalized
pain. Alright,
so Cindy, we'll give
you your 300 points.
We'll make Cindy
team number two.
So when you're doing the
health history, right, when
you're talking about joint
pain, one of the first
things you want to find
out is whether the pain is
coming from inside the
joint or whether it's extra
-articular coming from the
outside of the joint, right?
So there's a lot of muscles,
a lot of tendons that are
outside the joint that might
be causing pain, right?
For example, the patella
tendonitis, right, will be
extra-articular because
it's not really inside the
knee joint. It's more on the
outside. But they're still
going to present with knee
pain, right, versus an ACL
where that might be articular
pain, right, because
intra-articular pain because
it's coming from inside.
Pain can either be
acute or chronic.
You can have some inflammatory
versus non-inflammation,
localized versus diffused,
and it can involve
multiple joint or can
just involve one joint.
It could be related to
systemic issues, so you
have to know, do they
have any fever along with
the knee pain? Do they
have any weight loss,
weakness, any kind of unusual
rest that's developing?
And any associated
neck pain or back pain.
The first question
I like to ask any
patient when they
come in with pain is
I like to tell them
point to the pain.
If they point to the
pain, sometimes it's going
to make a lot more sense
of what you're dealing
with and what you're
going to be treating.
Because a patient can
come in with hip pain and
they might actually say
that I have back pain.
But when they point,
they're pointing to the hip.
You're going to determine
again whether the
pain is one pain, is
it inside this joint
or is it extra articular,
is it acute, chronic,
and then again localized
versus diffuse.
So again one joint, multiple
joint, is it going from
one joint to another joint
or is it happening all at
the same joint at the
same time and is it more
systemic where it's spreading
from one joint to another.
Articular, right, is
it two pains from the
joint, extra-articular,
is it involving everything
that's outside that
joint, whether it's a
bone, muscle, tissue
that's around the joint.
It occurs in inflammation,
you might have a bursa
that becomes inflamed,
you might have the
tendon, tendonitis,
a strain versus a
strain, so when you talk
about ligament, ligament
can be sprained,
and that's when you
have a stressing
or tearing of the ligament.
Alright, so very good
work, Cindy. Thank you
for starting off the
game. And the next
category, what would
you like to pick, Cindy?
I will try All
About Me for $400.
Alright, so we're going to
do All About Me for $400.
During your history taken,
you asked the patient to
describe the inciting event
leading up to the pain.
Maria you had your hands
up first what would you say
it is what is mechanism of
injury that is correct so
Maria 400 points and that
is mechanism of injury right
you always want to know
how did the pain happen how
did it occur what were you
doing at the time of the
pain right was it a contact
injury was it non-contact
injury all right so 400
points to Maria for mechanism
and when you get a mechanism
of injury right and
that's also going to be
documented MOI sometimes during
if If you're ever reading
somebody else's note, they
may say MOI, a mechanism
of injury is always going
to give you an idea of what
the injury is in itself.
And I'll just give you
a couple of examples.
You have a runner that's
running and he said he
steps in a hole and now he
hyperextends his knee. Now
you're going to be
thinking that you have that
posterior translation of the
PCL, of the tibia causing
an injury to the PCL, or
to the right over here,
you have a dashboard
injury. You have a dashboard
injury that hits on the
knee and the tibia is going
to go backwards. It's
going to rip apart the PCL.
Whether you get hit,
this is a contact
injury over here,
you get hit and now
you have either a
varus or a valgus.
So in this case we're
going to have a valgus
reaction and that's
going to put a sprain
on the inside of the
knee joint or the MCL.
And then ACL, we mentioned
in the other lecture,
you could get unusual
twisting of the
hyperextended knee as in
landing after you hit a
basketball shot. Or you're
running in one direction
and then you cut to
the opposite direction.
So very good,
Maria. Thank you for
your answer. We will
go back to the main
board, and Maria,
you get the pick.
Sherlock Holmes investigating
the pain for 200.
We're going to go for 200.
Four cardinal features
of inflammation
are pain, swelling,
warmth, and this.
And Cindy, you
had your hand up.
What is redness?
That is correct.
So the answer is redness.
Alright, so we're going
to give you 200 points.
Any time you have any kind
of inflammation, right,
or an inflammatory injury,
right, it's going to
be pain, swelling, warmth,
and redness that you're
going to be looking for
in a physical exam, right.
A lot of different causes,
right, we're not going to
go too detailed into the
lecture, but there's a lot
of different causes that
can cause inflammation,
whether it's infectious
versus non-infectious, right,
whether it's gout versus
non-gout, crystal-related.
But non-inflammatory,
we're thinking more about
trauma, we're thinking about
overuse injury, repetitive
use injuries, degenerative
changes, fibromyalgia.
So we're going to assess
when we do the history
taken, what kind of
limited movements
that the patient have.
They're going to tell you,
Doc, I used to be able
to walk three blocks,
now I can't even walk out
of the house. So we want
to try to determine what
kind of limited movements
they're going to have.
Timing, is it acute
versus chronic?
How long is this going on
for? Have you ever had this
pain before and we want to
make sure they don't have
any other systemic features
right that's going to
be more significant so with
that being said keep up
the good work good job
cindy and uh cindy the board
goes back to you um i'll
try special testing for 400.
uh so we are going to do uh
I use what other cat
what category did
you want to do special
testing for 400
um how about for this sake we
do uh Sherlock home for 400.
sure i don't know or we could
ah let's do Sherlock home
all right we're already on
a roll with that category
all right so we're gonna
do a category five for 400.
um an inventory of the body
system that is obtained
through a series of questions
in order to identify signs
and symptoms what the
patients may be experiencing.
Cindy, you had
your hand up first.
Maria, you came
so close. Sorry.
Cindy, what do you think?
What is reviewer systems?
That is your reviewer
system. Very important
that we get our
reviewer systems in
these because we want to
make sure we're not
missing anything systemic.
So Cindy will give
you another 400.
And some of the common
review system that we
want to know is kind of
think constitutional. Do
they have any fevers,
chills, fatigue, right?
Dermatology, any wrath,
head, any injury that's
associated, head injury, what
other type of injury that you
might have had, any associated
neck pain, chest pain,
palpuration. And so these
are all the different
system that you can you can
choose from and you want to
ask a couple of questions
and when you guys get into
your DPR2 and the minimum
that they're going to require
right for the CSA is at
least three different systems
at least two different
symptoms for every system
so thinking about the diagnosis
think about how old the
patient is right you're
not going to get a 20 year
old that comes in with severe
osteoarthritis that would
be very very rare versus
somebody that might be 70
years old I think about
the age of the pace and the
pain, right? What was the
onset, location, occurrence?
Are they hearing any
kind of snapping sounds?
Do they feel like anything
coming out of place?
What are they using to
get around the house? Are
they using anything to
help them with ambulation?
And what kind of activity
tolerance do they have?
What were they able to do?
Any change in distance?
Maybe they used to
run a mile a day and
now they're running 10
miles a day, right? And
that significant increase
can cause an overuse
injury and different
injuries in that aspect.
Any trauma that you might
have been associated
with, car accidents,
we talked about
the dashboard injury
causing a PCL injury.
What was the mechanism,
activity, what do you
like to do, how physical
are you during the
daytime? Are you sitting
at a desk nine hours a day
or are you getting up
and you're moving around
all day long? Any neurological
symptoms, numbness,
tingling, now we talk
about potential for
maybe radiculopathy or
some kind of neuropathy.
and so continues to
do a great work Cindy
you're on a roll what's
your next category
I will try something different
this time I'll do hip
hip hooray for a hundred
we're going hip hip hooray
for 100 the hip is classified
as this type of joint
Cindy, what is a ball
and socket joint?
Let's see,
and that is what is a
ball and socket joint.
So we'll give you
your 100 points.
So I mentioned in the other
lecture when we talked
about the hip, in order
to have a ball and
socket joint, you have to
have a ball and a socket.
So the ball is going to
be your femoral head, and
it's going to be going
right into the acetabulum.
There's a lot of
different factors that
makes it a very,
very stable joint.
So again, it's going
to be a very stable
joint, so when you
have something very
stable, you lose a
lot of flexibility.
It's a little different
than the shoulder
because you have a lot
of flexibility, but
you're going to lose
a lot of stability.
So anyway, with the hip,
what makes it so stable?
It has a lot of muscles.
It has a lot of cartilage
and ligaments, and it has an
alteration of relationship
between the femur and
the acetylchabular fossa.
right, and that can result
in undue wear and our
disruption of the caudalus,
right, so that's a potential
source of pain that you
might have because there's
a lot of structures that
surround the hip joint.
So the hip is an
acetabular femoral joint,
right, so acetabulum
into the femur, and
it's encased by a
fibrous capsule, right,
that joins the central
joint cavity, right.
It originates from the
acetabular rim and inserts
on the intratrochenteric
line of the femur.
This is all part of the
anatomy that we discussed
in the previous lecture,
and that capsule
is lined by the synovial
fluid, so you have a lot
of vicious synovial
fluid that makes it less
painful when you're doing
day-to-day activity.
You could imagine you only had
bone, but you didn't
have any fluid.
Then the bone would be
hitting on bone all day long,
and at the end of the
day, it could be painful.
and so I've been doing
an awesome job let's keep
it moving so Cindy you
got the last question
right what category do
you want to go into now um
I guess I'll continue a
hip hip hooray 200 we're
gonna go hip hip hooray
for 200 this muscle
serves as the primary
flexor of the hip Maria you
up the time what is
iliopsoas muscle right on
good job that is uh the
iliopsoas muscle for 200
and uh this muscle is
pretty important because it
serves as the primary flexor
of the hip joint right so
the iliopsoas is primary
movements is flexing and
extension and it provides
muscular support of the hip
right during everyday
activity every time you walk
you're going to be flexing
and then extending your hip.
And then the opposite of
that would be the gluteus
maximus, which served
as a primary extensor.
All right, very impressive.
So Maria, you get
the board again?
All right, I'll
turn a new category,
knee to succeed for 100.
All right, so knee
to succeed for 100.
The knee is classified
as this type of joint.
Maria, that was quick.
What do you think?
Hinge joint. What
is hinge joint?
And that is correct.
What is the hinge joint?
I would have took hinge
type synovial joint,
but hinge joint is very,
very commonly used.
So Maria, we're going
to give you 100 points.
And a couple of
things about the knee.
I'm going to bring up my pen.
The primary function
as the hinge joint with
the articulation between
the femur and the
tibia as the main load
-bearing. So the tibia
is going to be the
main load-bearing bone.
The distal femur,
when it comes down,
it's going to widen,
and that's going to
give you your medial
and lateral condyle.
The distal femur and
the proximal tibia are
ticular surfaces with
hyaline cartilage,
and basically it's going
to be surrounded by
hyaluronic acid. it's
going to be surrounded by
lubricant that's going to
help the knee not feel so
much pain every time you're
walking and every time
you're bending your knee.
And in addition to the
femur and the tibia and
the fibula, we're going
to have the patella,
which is a large septimoid
bone that functions at the
insertion of the quadricep
and the origin of the
infrapatellar ligament.
And then we have the
fibula, right, which allows
for rotation of the lower
leg without sacrificing
stability of the lower
leg. So the proximal
end of the fibular head
articulates medially
with the lateral portion
of the sivial plateau.
So the muscles of the knee,
what's going to make the
knee stronger when they
come in for physical therapy
and rehab is we always
want to work on the muscles
surrounding the knee. So
what's going to extend the knee
is the quadriceps. And
we learn in anatomy that
there's four muscles because
the quadriceps means four.
right, this ball muscle that
makes up the quadriceps.
As far as the flexors,
right, what's going to
flex the knee is going
to be the hamstring,
right, and this
also crosses the hip
and acts as an
extensor of the hip,
right, and those
muscles are going to
be the semitendinosus,
the gracilis, and
the long head and
the bicep femoris.
And then you also have the
gastroc and the plantaris.
So a picture sometimes
speaks a lot louder.
So here we have your quadriceps
muscles and we have
your hamstrings.
And these are future
doctors, even though
they aren't going
into ophthalmology and
urology, they sure do
know their musculoskeletal
system, because
they went to NYICOM.
And Maria, you get to
pick the next category.
All right, I'll
choose Need to Succeed
for 500. Knees to
secede for 500.
This structure in the knee
caresses the posterior
tibia to the medial femoral
condyle and prevents
the tibia from sliding
backwards on the femur.
Maria.
What is posterior
cruciate ligament?
That is correct. Also
known as the PCL.
and so the posterior
cruciate ligament is the
answer and we can't forget
to give you your points
there we go all right so
when we talk about the pcl
and the acl right the
knee makes up a lot of
ligaments right it's made
up of the acl the anterior
cruciate ligament the
posterior cruciate ligament um
it's probably the anatomy
right i always like to
take my fingers and you can
kind of take your fingers
like this question in front
of you if you're taking
an exam and you don't want
to things too much into
it now you take a finger
to cross it like this if
you can see me through
my video and um see the
picture right down here now
you see this is my right
knee and you can kind of
see that the acl is going
from the lateral femoral
condyle and it's going into
the medial direction
right and the pcl which is
my other finger is going
into the lateral direction
beginning at the medial
femoral condyle and then
you also have the medial
collateral ligament and
lateral collateral ligament
and these connect the
epicondyle to the tibia or
the fibula respectively.
We
have another diagram,
another picture. The picture
is always good to look
at. So we see that the
femur comes down and
it's kind of widened into
the medial condyle and
the lateral epicondyle.
And then on the medial
side, you're going to have
the medial collateral
ligament. The lateral side,
you're going to have the
lateral collateral ligament.
Within the knee itself,
intraarticular within
the knee, you're going
to have a C-shaped
cartilage structure
that attaches the tibial
plateau to the meniscal
tibial ligament.
This is a primary help
stabilize the femoral tibial
articulation, and it helps
with a lot of different
things, whether it's weight
transfer, proprioception
within the knee, and any
kind of nutritional function
for the articular cartilage.
So the menisci is more like
a cushion between the upper
leg and the lower leg.
So you guys are on a roll, just
like butter, you're on a roll.
So Maria, I believe you get the
next question,
the next category.
Okay, I'll choose
All About Me for 500.
We've got All About Me for 500.
When this ligament
is torn, you may
see the patella say
bye-bye and move
to the lateral
position of the knee.
Maria, you have your hand up.
Alright, what is
medial patellofemoral
ligament? Very
good. Very big word.
A lot of different
words, but the cool thing
about this very big
word, it kind of makes
sense because it's on
the medial side. it
connects the patella to
the femur on the medial
side, right? So it kind
of makes sense, MPFL.
So that is MPFL, medial
patellofemoral ligament.
We can't forget the 500 points,
Maria takes the lead, 1700.
So you're going to have
the MPFL, a very, very
important structure. The
MPFL is a very important
structure, and I can tell
you that this NPFL, it's an
important structure in
stabilizing the patella. So
when that NPFL rupture,
right, now you're going to
see that patella go to the
lateral side. And you've
seen in my other lecture,
I talked about Patrick
Mahome, and everybody knows
Patrick Mahome now because
we just had the Super
Bowl, and he's been winning
Super Bowls, and he
actually had a patella
dislocation a couple years
ago, right, and we kind of
see how how that plays a
role in stabilizing the
patella. So it stabilizes
the ligament. It has an
essential role in resisting
natural lateral migration.
This lateral migration of the
patella is going to happen
because of the quad. So
sometimes people develop a
very strong quad but the
NPFL might be a little weak
and then all of a sudden
the quads contract and now
you're going to have a lateral
migration of the patella.
It often ruptures in
patella dislocation and when
it's torn you can see a
lateral patellar instability
along with the lateral
migration of the patella
okay so uh that was a hard
question but um we always
have a lot of confidence
in our fourth years so
very well done and maria
you get the next category
all right sherlock
holmes investigating
the pain for 100.
all right sherlock
holmes investigating
in the pain for 100.
After obtaining a detailed
history taking, a physician
will move on to the next
part of the encounter.
Cindy, you got your hand up.
What is the physical exam?
Let's see, what is the
physical exam is correct. You
do your history taking
first, you get an idea of
what the potential diagnosis
might be, and then you
go right on to the physical
jam so we're going to
make sure we give Cindy
100 points the physical jam
should always be systematic
right you don't want to
be all over the place
because then it's going to
throw you off and you're and
you're coming up with the
differential and making sure
that you cover everything
and so the easiest
thing to do the pace is
walking right a lot of time
if I'm covering a football
game and the football
player comes in with hip or
knee pain I want to see how
they walk off the field,
right? I want to see how
they're walking off the
field. I want to see how
the patient is walking into
the office, right? If I
didn't get to see them
walk in the office, I might
say, you know, can you
stand up? Let me see you
walk three or four steps,
right? And then I just
kind of see how much pain
they're in and where they're
pointing to the pain,
right? Just like everything
else, we always want to
look before we, uh, before
we test. So we're going to
look, inspection, make sure
we don't see any abnormality.
Make sure, for example,
um, I looked at some of
patella and it was out
of place right that's you
just know that just on
inspection right i didn't need
to do any other exam i knew
he had a patella dislocation
i knew he somebody else
had a shoulder dislocation
right just by inspection
right so you're going to
look then you're going to
palpate find out where the
pain is coming from range
of motion right don't forget
active and passive right
what is active active is
when the patient is doing
the work and passive is when
the patient is not doing
the work the doctor is
moving the extremities or
whatever it might be for them
And then after range
of motion, we're
going to test strength
testing, and then
we're going to do our
additional testing.
Again, you're going to
assess the four signs
of inflammation, not to
repeat it, but swelling,
warmth, redness, and
pain or tenderness.
And so the first thing
we're going to do when we're
in the DPR lab and when we're
examining any patient, we
just want to see how are
they walking, right? So we
might have them walk to the
end of the hallway, come
back, and we're going to
have them do a heel to toe
tandem walking right or they
could do the shallow bilateral
knee bend squats right
so these are all possible
um examinations you can
perform right on the patient
right a lot of time
if they're bending the
knee and they're trying
to walk they might have
an injury to the
meniscus right that might
be a painful thing that
might be something that
maybe they are not
able to do on their own
inspection of the hip right
you always want to make
sure that when you're
inspecting somebody or something
right always say it out
loud right it's going
to a lot of benefits a
they're going to know that
you're looking at for any
kind of any deformity or
anything you might see or
mouth muscle abnormality
but it's also going to let
the standard of patients
know that you have to
leave during the inspection
and you're not jumping to
a pump patient uh you're
going to look at the anterior
posterior and lateral
and you're going to jab
in the hip for any kind of
abnormality muscle estrophy
or any kind of swelling
so again look at the
knees look at the anterior
posterior and lateral and
again don't forget to say
I'm looking at your knees
all right so here we have
a class of 2021 actually
performing a knee examination
on another class of
2021 all right after you
inspect you're going to
palpate right it's always
going to be a bilateral
exam so you always have to
look at both sides and And
the patient could be in
the lateral recumbent
position. And you're going to
palpate. These are some
of the landmarks. We're
going to go through them
during DPR lab. And these
are all landmark potentials
that if they have pain.
Sometimes by palpating
something at a specific area,
for example, in the ASIS,
you can say to yourself,
okay, what tendon attaches
to the ASIS? So maybe it's
not pain on the bone itself,
but maybe it's pain on
a tendon or a ligament
that attaches to that area.
All right, so you guys
are doing amazing work.
Very well done.
And I'm turning off my pen, and
we'll go back to
the home screen.
I think, Cindy, you got
that question right.
So you get the next category.
Now continue with
Hip Hip Hooray
for 300. Hip Hip
Hooray for 300.
We're checking
range of motions.
Bringing the leg away from the
body will induce this motion.
Maria, you guys have
a hand up first.
What is abduction?
Abduction, that is correct.
Abduction.
So Maria, we're going to
give you 300 points, and
so
When we talk about range
of motion, we always
want to know what range
of motion we're putting
them through All right
So when you bring the hip
up and the pace is playing
on their back, you're
going to get flexion And
when they're bringing
the leg back, you're
going to get extension,
right external
rotation So even though
you're bringing
the lower leg in
You're really looking
at what's happening at
the hip joint, right?
So at the hip joint,
you're going to get
external rotation at the tip
joint You're going to
get internal rotation.
I add you're adding to
the body, right? You can't
really do a true abduction
because the other leg is
going to be in the way, but
you're going to lift the
leg up just a little bit
and then bring it across.
And that's going to
give you abduction,
and then this is
going to be abduction.
And notice that the doctor
is doing the work for the
patient. So is that going
to be active or passive?
That is going to be passive
because the patient is not
doing anything, and the
doctor is doing it for them.
So first thing you're going to
do is active range of motion.
Again, flexion, extension,
external rotation, abduction,
bring it away from the body
and so this leg is going
away from the body and
then um adduction that you
could bring the leg up and
then you bring it across and
then our internal rotation
as well all right so that's
active range of motion
um when we talk about hip
evaluation and you're
examining range of motion right
don't get so caught up on
the number because nobody's
ever going to ask you on a
test whether it's 120 degrees
or 130 degrees right but a
lot of different resources
will have a lot of different
information right so
i'm using this to be consistent
with the omm department
right we're going to be
consistent with the omm
department these are the
range of motion right that's
classically you might see okay
some people naturally might
have a lower range of
motion some people might be
higher right and this is
just a very broad range group
uh flexion again 120 to
130 degrees flexion of the
hip with the knee extended
is a good way to test
out the flexibility of the
hamstring so if this leg
was extended now you got
to bring the leg up right
you are going to test out
the hamstring right but
you want to relax the
hamstring and really focus
on the hip joint now you're
going to bend the knee
uh extension right now you're
testing out the extension
and abduction right the
doctor is bringing the
patient away the leg
away from the body right
that's going to be a
passive range of motion
and a deduction, external
rotation, and
internal rotation.
Alright, so again,
very nice work.
Alright, so it is a very
close game, anybody's game.
So we will go back
to the home board.
And I think Maria got
that last question
right. So Maria, you
get the next category.
Alright, need to
succeed for 400. We are
going to do the knee
to succeed for 400.
So knee to succeed for 400.
While examining for
range of motion,
you ask the patient
to bend your knee,
causing this type
of knee movement.
Cindy, you just beat
Maria, sorry Maria,
Cindy, what's the answer?
What is flexion?
The answer is what is flexion.
Bending your knee is going to
create flexion in
the knee joint.
So again,
range of motion of the
knee, right, here's
some more numbers, right,
if you like numbers.
But again, don't memorize
the exact numbers because
it's going to be a very, very
broad range among different
resources based on what
resources you're using.
So knee flexion is going
to be about 145, and I say
about, it's not always
going to be exact. everybody
has different normal right
for about 145 to 150 knee
extension is going to be
zero to negative um zero to
five degrees and then our
rotation varies with the
amount of flexion of the
knee so if you have full
extension of the knee
that's going to be almost no
rotation but if you bend
the knee to 90 degrees right
flexing might be a 45 degrees
external rotation and you
might get 30 degrees on
internal rotation and then
various and valgus you're
not going to really expect
too many uh too many degrees
right it's going to be
very limited right unless
you have an injury to the
mcl or the pcl uh knee
active range of motion so
here we have active flexion
right the patience is doing
the work and so we have
active flexion and then um
we're going to have
internal and external
rotation. So if somebody
says swing your leg
inside, right, that's
going to be internal
rotation, and then
swing your leg
outside is going to
be external rotation.
So again, towards the
midline, swinging your leg
towards the midline, right,
internal rotation, and then
swing your leg away from
the midline is going to be
external rotation and
then flexion and extension
and knowing the primary
muscle group that's going to
be affected by the uh by
by the movement of the knee
next after that um after
vein diversion right we're
going to test the strength
of the knee right so here
we have resistance
extension right we call this
resisted extension and not
resisted flexion is because uh
the patient the patient
you always name everything
towards the patient so it's
like the patient's right
side the patient's left side
we don't name it by what
we see we name it by what
the patient by according
to the patient so here the
patient is trying to extend
so she's trying to extend
so that's resistance
extension and now she's trying
to flex right she's trying
to flex her knees now we
have resistance flexion
and that takes us to our
break but very very cool
about this is that there's
no commercials and if you
watch Jeopardy on tv you
got to go through a couple
of commercials and so we're
going to begin with Cindy
Lin who is a Nikon class
for 2024 just recently
matched into urology
residency at Albany Medical
College so Cindy can you
explain what the moment was
like the moment you found
out um what you asked yeah
it was definitely very nerve
-wracking like i was home
in the morning and i got
the email with the results
and i was too scared to
open it so i walked up to
my sister i was like can
you open the email for me
she's like no so i opened
it but then instead i
actually had a link so i had
to run to my computer and
like click on the link
and it popped out that i
matched albany's i ran out
and the first thing is there
I was like hug my mom and
I was like I passed you.
Congratulations and that's
very well deserved right
so a lot of hard work it
all begins in the first year
it even begins before med
school now you got to get
into med school and then
you go through four years
of med school but at the
end of the day watching all
these videos and powerpoint
presentation and it's
jammed after lab practicals
and so much going on at the
end of the day it all
becomes worthwhile so Cindy
congratulations to you thank
you congratulations cindy
thank you and maria can
you tell me what the moment
was like for you the moment
you found out where you
were going yeah i was also
at home um i didn't have
anyone around me but i
remember checking my email and
going on the website and i
was just so excited i was
over the moon so happy i was
extremely nervous waiting
to find out but But when
I did, I was so excited.
I called everyone I've ever
known, my family first.
And yeah, so I'm
really grateful
and I'm excited
for this journey.
And Maria, congratulations
and very well done.
And correct me if I'm wrong,
you were a BSDO yourself?
Yes, I was a BSDO
from SUNY Geneseo
and NYITCon. All
right, very cool.
Congratulations and best
wishes to you both. And again,
thank you both for joining
us for this very important
lecture for the first
year of medical students.
thank you and we
actually spent some time
together during our
rotation right so we got
to go to rock study
boxing we did some uh
pre-fight physicals
for the mma shows and
again we have uh cindy
lind matching urology at
alban medical college maria
cannellos ophthalmology
at june downstate so
hopefully you guys will stay
in contact with the medical
school i'm sure that a
lot of people that want
to continue to see you
just to see it and hear
from you definitely and now
the time come we have to
go back to the game I think
that was a lot better
than commercials right so
we will go back to the
game and if I get this
correct the person that
got the last question right
was Cindy so I see you get
the next Great question.
I would do All
About Me for 200.
So All About Me for 200.
Special testing of
the hip includes
Trendelenburg test.
Essentially a test that
checks the weakness
of the gluteus length.
Cindy.
I believe it's the
gluteus medius. So what is
gluteus medius? That is
correct. And that is 100%
right. that is the gluteus
medius so I'm going to
give Cindy 200 points
and I think going back I
don't think I gave the 500
points to the 400 points
when we did knee flexing
Cindy got 400 points so
that was an error on my
end right but I will give
you your 400 points for
getting knee flexing
correct so the correct
score is now 1,700 to 2,000.
When we talk about
the hip, we have
a lot of special
testing for the hip.
I've kind of put it all
on one page, one slide,
so that when you guys
are reviewing it, it's
nice that you can just
kind of see it all on one
slide and have an idea
of what testing for
what joint and what
structure you're looking at.
So Trendelenburg is the
first test we're going
to look at. It's testing
for the gluteus medius.
And what
Trindalenburg is going to
be testing for is the way we
do testing for Trindalenburg
is that the patient
stands on one leg on the
unaffected side and then and then
on the affected side. So
they're going to do this
test two times and you're
going to look at the pelvic.
So here we have a normal
exam and you can kind of know
that the pelvic stays even,
right? The patient lifts
this leg up and the pelvic
is staying even. But now
on the on the abnormal one,
right, the patient lifts
this leg up and the pelvic
is coming down. I'm going
to exaggerate the line but
the pelvic is coming down.
What that's going to mean
on this right side he can
have a weak gluteus medius.
He's going to have a weak
abductor. And that indicates
the inability of the hip.
Abductor has stabilized
the pelvic on the femur.
And that's going to be weak.
So that's something you
see on examination. That
could be a source of pain.
That could be something
that you work on um in
physical therapy so uh
the iliac crest again just
another picture right we just
saw the video the picture
kind of shows that he lift
this leg up and now the
hip is going to drop and
that's going to be the
gluteus medius injury all
right so i keep continuing
to do great work uh cindy
you got that last question
right i'm getting rid of
the pen and we're going
to go back to the home
board and Cindy, you're up.
I will try special
testing for 400.
If this test seems to
the right, it's positive,
usually indicating intra
-articular hip pathology.
Cindy, you're up.
What is the central
test? That is correct.
You remember that from
first? yeah very well done so
we'll give you your 400
points so Cindy just took
the lead and that is thin
field test and basically what
you're testing for intra
-articular hip pathology
and you're gonna have the
patient on their back and
then the extended right
you're gonna actively actively
the patient's gonna do it
on their own actively raise
their leg off while the
examiner applied manual
resistance right and that's
going to be reduced to
reducible pain usually in
the groin, gluteal region, or
greater trochanter, and
that is intra-hip pathology.
And here we have
another picture.
We're also going to talk
about Patrick's test. Patrick
is when you're going to
bring the leg up into
flexion, and then you're
going to AB duck. You're going
to bring the knee to the
side, to the outside.
You're going to create an
external rotation, external
rotation of the hip, and
then now you're going to
bring it down, and that's
going to be your extension.
When this test is painful,
the pain is going to
be from movement, and this
is another way to test
for any kind of hip joint
pathology or any kind
of SI dysfunction or any
kind of muscular pain.
So this is going
to be Patrick's
test, also known
as Faber's test.
Why do they name
it Faber's test?
It's because you have the F,
you have the AB,
you have the E, and the R.
So F, abduction, and
external rotation.
Another diagram,
another picture.
This came from the
OMM department.
And another picture, because we
like to see a lot of pictures.
This is also used to
test out the SI joint.
So again, one hand on
the opposite side, and
the other hand is on
the inside of the knee.
creating pressure
going downward.
And that's going to
be, pain is going
to be referred to
the groin, is more
suggestive of hip
pain pathology.
Pain that's localized
to the back when sudden
pressure is applied is
going to be more for
sacroiliac pathology. So
pain in the back, SI joint,
pain in the groin is
going to be hip joint.
And that's something that
when you're doing the
exam it's going to give you
a clue of where the pain
and where the source of
the pain is going to be.
And the next test is going
to be the log rule. Very,
very non-pacific uh we
don't even if it's positive
it's not going to give us
so much information because
there could be a lot of
different things there could
be but basically um they
need hold an extension by the
examiner and there's going
to be pain with movement
all right so that type of
movement is going to create
pain very non-pacific um it
could represent a fracture
of the hip but not
necessarily right and if you
have some kind of popping
sensation or popping sound
right that could also mean
a label chair in the hip.
We're going to go to
Fadir and Ferris chest. So
Fadir, we have F, which
is flexing, AD, ducting,
and internal rotation.
So we have the hip flex,
we're going to AD duct,
bringing it towards
the body, and we're
creating internal rotation.
We're going to be looking
for quantity, how it
is compared to the other
side. That's why we
do everything on both
sides. We want to look from
one side versus the
other, and that could
indicate whether there's
impingement or any kind
of muscular problem with
the other piriformis.
So that was very well done.
I'm going to get
rid of the pen.
All right so keep
up the great work we
will go back to the
board and I believe
Cindy you got the
last question right?
Yes so I will try again
special testing for
200. All right, so
special testing for 200.
This test, well, let's just
say normal would be minimal
distance between the
popliteal crease to the table.
And, Maria, you got
it before Cindy.
What is Thomas' test?
That is Thomas' test.
And that is
correct. We're going
to give you your 200 points. So
that is Thomas' test,
very, very commonly seen,
very commonly tested.
You're going to see
this a lot in any special
seat you're going to.
Somebody comes in and
they're having pain.
Sometimes they describe
it as hip pain.
And then you do this tummy
test, very simple test
to do. Have them lay down
on their back. They're
going to flex both
knees to the chest. And
you're going to allow one
leg to extend at a time.
And notice that in
this picture that the
knee is coming down,
the popliteal area
is going to come down
right to the table.
Now, let's say the
alleopsoas muscle or the hip
flexor is tight, that
tightness is going to create
more flexion in the
hip, and now you have
more flexion in the hip,
you're going to get that
little bit of gap right
there between the knee.
Everybody might have
a little bit of a gap,
but if you have a
significant gap right there,
significant, then it's
going to signify that they
have a tight hip flexor.
And a lot of people do,
it might be hypotonic, and
that's a lot of different
exercises you can do to
make it more flexible.
And the other thing
I wanted to bring up
with Thomas test is
that it ends with an AS.
If you look at psoas,
psoas ends with an AS.
So a lot of people like to
mess up Thomas and Thompson.
So Thompson ends in
an ON, that's the
Achilles tendon,
but thomas ends in
an AS and so does
psoas end in an AS.
So here, check the distance.
right this is somebody
with a tight hip flexor and
then now we have Erickson's
test another different test
where the patient will put
our hand on the ileum
bilaterally and we apply medial
pressure towards the SI
joint right if the patient
has pain when you're doing
this they're going to point
to the back and usually
the pain is going to be at
the SI joint right and that
might signify that they
have some kind of inflammation
or injury at the SI
joint uh so very well done
uh I think it was Maria that
got that last question
right so I'm gonna get rid
of the pen and Maria you
got the category all right
I'll do hip hip hooray for
400 hip hip hooray for 400
oh I wish I knew this
test patient was laying on
their side with their
hips and knees flexed and
the upper leg is passively
abducted and then and
then extended then
lowered to the table by
evaluating for a tight IT
band, for ileo-tibial band.
Cindy, you had
your hand up first.
I believe it's the
over test. That
is 100%. That is the over test.
So we're going to
give Cindy 400 points.
And what is the over test?
So over test, the
patient's lying on that
side, and the examiner
is going to be
behind the patient and
the hips and knees are
flexed, and the upper
leg is passively,
that means the doctor is
going to bring this leg up.
The doctor brings the leg up,
and then he lets the leg drop.
And as it's dropping,
normally it's
going to go straight
down. That's normal.
If somebody has
a tight IT band,
you can kind of see that delay
as the leg is coming down.
That delay is going to be due
to contracture of the IT band.
Over his chest, again,
looking at a diagram, you can
kind of see that the IT
band comes to the lateral
portion of the knee, and
sometimes that lateral portion
of the knee is going to be
where the injury is going
to occur, or where the
pain is going to feel pain,
and that IT band throughout
might be very, very tight.
You can also do the
periformis chest.
So the periformis chest,
the patient is
supine, flex the hip,
and we flex the hip and
knee, and we're going to have
active abduction. That means
the patient is going to
try to bring their knee and
they're going to push out.
So while they're pushing
out, you're pushing in.
If they have pain over
the posterior aspect
of the greater trochanter,
you might think
that they have some
kind of periformis,
spasm.
Very well done.
Time to move on.
So we'll go back to the board.
And I believe it was Cindy that
got the last question, right?
I will continue with
hip hip hooray for 500.
Alright, so she's
going big, 500.
When performing the hip
drop test, the patient is
asked to bend one knee
while both feet remain
flat on the floor and the
other knee is straight.
If the greatest
drop is on the right
side, the side of
the greater lumbar
side bending will
be on this side.
Maria?
What is the left
side? That 100%,
that is the left
side. Very well done.
So, basically,
with the hip drop test,
the patient's standing
with their feet apart
about four to six inches,
and what they're going to
do is without lifting the
leg up, they're going to
be asked to bend one knee
while both feet remain
flat on the floor and the
other knee is straight.
and so you're gonna compare
both sides and the side
with the greatest drop of
the iliac crest is opposite
side of the greatest lumbar
side bending and so that's
a lot of words so when
we have a lot of words
we like to go look at a
picture and so pictures is
sometimes a lot better than
a lot of words so here we
have the right hip drop
and now that right hip is
dropping it's creating a
side bending to the
opposite side so that's
what we mentioned before
you're creating a side
bending to the left
side or you have greater
convexity to the same
side that's dropping.
So the hip is dropping,
you've got the
side bending, that's
the concavity side,
and then you have the
convexity side. We
have an example, so that
right hip is dropping,
or not the left hip, but
now we're going to look at
the right hip drop. The right
hip is dropping and you're
creating that concavity on
the left side we are going
to go so before we continue
we're going to dedicate
this Alexis to Alex of X
forever in our hearts always
in our always in inspiration
and I'm always trying to
build a gentler kinder
society if we all do a little
bit and now we're going to
get there so thank you to Alex
and we will go back to the
board right so we have a
very close game and Maria
you got the last question
right okay I'll go for special
testing 300 special testing
for 300 old McDonald had
a farm and on the mommy
hurt his knee he injured
the injured mcdonald had a
mcmurray test done suggesting
a chair to this structure
which is no fun and cindy
you're up what is a meniscus
injury that is a meniscus
injury very well done and so
we're going to give you 300
points and now we're going
to talk about some of the
special testing for the
knee just like we did for
the hip uh mcmurray's test is
one we're going to talk
about first talking about
meniscus and then we have the
athlete compression athlete
distraction and we're going
to kind of go through we're
going to touch all these
in just a little bit uh so
with mcmurray test the purpose
of the mcmurray test is
the pinched and meniscus
between the tibia plateau and
the femoral condyle and so
again the examiner is going
to lift the leg supine and
one hand controlling the
ankle while the other hand
controls the distal femur
So the thing about this test
is that this test you're
going to create a hyperflexion
of the knee and then
you're going to internally
rotate the leg and you're
going to create a varus.
You're going to create a
varus movement because what
that's going to do is that's
going to create more pressure
on the medial meniscus.
So here we have a varus
and by putting that varus
you're compressing that
medial meniscus in between.
One thing I will mention
is that if you look this
up in different resources,
some will say that this
technique is testing
the lateral meniscus and
some will say this is
testing the medial meniscus.
So I went ahead and this
is the way when I did my
training in sports medicine,
we went by what this book
said right here, the
osteopathic clinical joint exam.
But you might see some other
resources where this is
saying this is actually
testing the lateral meniscus.
You're not going to be
tested, we talked about it
with the OMM department,
you won't be tested on what
meniscus is being tested,
because at the end of the
day the patient is going
to point to where the
pain is. So if you do this
test and they point to the
medial side, chances are
very high that they're
going to have a medial
meniscus rather than a lateral
meniscus. So again, don't
get so caught up on medial
meniscus versus lateral
meniscus. Just know that
this is testing
for the meniscus.
So again, the whole
purpose is to pinch the
torn meniscus between
the tibia and the femur.
and now we have just the
opposite right you want to
check out the lateral
meniscus and what you're going
to do you're going to
externally rotate the leg
externally rotate and now
you're going to create a valgus
so externally rotate the
leg create a valgus and now
you're going to put pressure
on that lateral meniscus
so to me when i do this
exam i'm thinking in my head
that lateral meniscus on
that outside of the knee
is being crunched together
by the uh by the two bones
On the athlete's compression
chest, right, the patient's
going to lay on their
abdomen, or they're going to
lay in a prone position,
and you're going to add
compression. Again, when you
add compression, right, to
the knee joint, right, you're
really pressing pressure
on the meniscus, right. So
you're pressing pressure on
the meniscus, and then you're
going to rotate the leg
in and out. And again, the
patient's going to point
to where they feel the pain.
If they point to the lateral
side, chances are the
injury is going to be on the
lateral side. If they're
pointing the medial side,
chances are the pain is going
to be on the medial side.
So I gave Cindy the
point before, so
we're going to go back
to the home board.
And Cindy, you get
the next category.
I would try need
to succeed 300.
Need to succeed for 300.
Similar to the
athlete compression
test that we just talked about,
the examiner will grab
the patient's ankle and it
internally and externally
while a distracting force
is applied. You're testing
for these two structures.
Cindy, you have
your hand up first.
I'm testing for what is the
medial collateral ligament
and the lateral collateral
ligament. That is 100%
correct. Medial collateral and
lateral collateral ligament.
Just know that some
terminology, some textbooks
may say tibial collateral
ligament, but you know tibial
is on the medial side,
fibular collateral ligament
is on the outside. and we're
going to make sure Cindy
gets her points, we're going
to give her 300 points.
And here is the athlete's
distraction test,
alright, so we're going
to lift the leg up,
the force is going to
go up, and we're going
to rotate the leg in
different directions,
right, pulling up on
the leg, and you're
going to internally
and externally rotate,
right. Pain is going
to be significant for
a ligament injury,
versus before we were
going down we person
against the ministers.
Very outstanding work.
We're going to move
on back to the board
and Cindy you're up again.
Now try special
testing for 100.
We're going to do a
special testing for 100.
A football player
evaluated on the field
using glassman chess
which is testing for the
integrity of this
structure in the knee.
Cindy you have your hand up.
What's the ACL?
100% for 100 points you
got the ACL also known
as the anterior anterior
cruciate ligament
so we're going to give
another 100 points to
Cindy and when we talk
about Lachman tests and
basically you're going
to lift them you're going
to flex the knee to
about 15 to 30 degrees
you're going to flex the knee
to about 15 to 30 degrees,
and the examiner is going
to use a distal hand,
right, distal hand, to
pull the tibia anteriorly,
right. What you're looking
for, you're looking for
increased laxity. If you
don't know if you have
increased laxity, a good
way to find out is check the
other side. If you check
the other side, and that
has less laxity, and now
you check the right side,
and they have increased
laxity, chances are they
have ACL insufficiency
or any kind of ACL chair,
right. Similar to laxming,
you have anterior drawer,
right, anterior drawer
test, you're going to have
the knee flexed to about
90 degrees and so knees
are flexed to 90 degrees
you're going to grab right
behind the tibia and
you're going to pull it
anteriorly all right so if
i'm pulling this anteriorly
and there's increased
laxity chances are very high
that they may have an acl
injury if not an acl chair
okay so uh now you can
diagnose a torn acl all
right very well done very
very common so you may see
this you might be covering
a game or whatever it
might be and you're diagnosed
to ACL on the field.
We're going to go
back Cindy you're up.
I'll finish up the
need to succeed 200.
Need to succeed for 200.
Similar to the
anterior drawer test
now with a translation
of the tibia
posteriorly examining
this structure.
Marie you had your hand up
just before Cindy what is
the posterior cruciate
ligament that is the posterior
cruciate ligament and
that is for 200 points uh
so very similar to the
anterior so it makes sense
you could do this at the
same time all right you're
testing the anterior where
you're going where you're
lifting it up now now you're
going to be testing the
posterior where the force
is going to be going this
way and what you're looking
for is you're looking
for excessive translation
when compared to the other
knee and sometimes you
might need to stabilize this
joint a little bit so you
can always put your knee
if you need to put your
knee on top of that foot
whatever you need to do to
kind of stabilize so you
keep a 90 degrees knee
flexion and now you can torn
now you can diagnose a
torn pcl and very well done
and maria i think i gave
you your points and we're
going to go to the next
category you get the pick okay
let's do all about me for
100 all about me for 100
uh this test known as valgus
stress test will create
a stress on the ligament
of this ligament of the
knee uh maria you're up um
medial cruciate ligament that
is correct that is actually
that is not correct.
I apologize that's the first
one we got wrong today.
Cindy, do you want
to give it a try?
What is the lateral
cruciate ligament?
That is unfortunately
uncorrect as well.
So that is the medial
collateral ligament.
So it's the medial
collateral ligament not the
medial cruciate ligament.
But do not feel bad
because we had a Jeopardy
game on January 14, 2021,
where the answer was
medial collateral ligament,
and they got the question
wrong. They said medial
cruciate ligament. They
sound so much alike. They
both have MCL, but it's the
answer cruciate ligament,
and you have the medial
collateral ligament.
All right, so when we talk
about the valgus, the L,
meaning this is how I remember
it, the L, meaning you're
bringing the lower leg
lateral and what you do there
is um you're testing that
medial knee so think about
that medial knee right now
when i bring this leg out
picture how upset that mcl
is going to be right there
all right that mcl is really
going to be stressed out
and that's going to be
painful for the uh for the
patient right and that indicate
a mcl inflammation or any
kind of disruption but
if we do just the opposite
it, and now we're putting,
if we do just the opposite,
now we do a varus, right,
take a look at that
outside of the knee, right,
think about where the LCL
is going to be, and that LCL
right now is going to be
very inflamed and very upset,
right, because you're
really stressing it out,
right, so that's going to
be injury to the lateral
collateral ligament if you're
creating a varus stress.
No worries about that
question, we will get the
next one. so I think
Maria you did get the last
question right you're
up okay let's do special
testing for 500 this test
seen seen here demonstrate
laxity of which of the
following structure Maria
what is patella that is
laxity of the patella
So, Maria, that's a
500-point question.
Very nicely done.
That's the patella,
in fact, they name it
patella laxity test or
patella apprehension, right?
Apprehension, the
patient's not going to
let you do it. They're
going to be a little
nervous about you doing
this to their knee. But
we look at what's normal
and what's abnormal,
right? So a positive test,
the patient's going to
have apprehension or
instability, right? Or they're
going to have increased
movement like that that's the
increased laxity right
there so that patient is
going to have increased
laxity versus this knee right
here which is more stable
and that can indicate
patella stability instability
or previous patella
dislocation and as a reminder
of patella dislocation
usually due to this quad
muscle pulling the patella to
the outside and that's
going to create a disruption
on the ligament on the
inside the medial patella
femoral ligament the medial
patella femoral ligament
and the patella grind test
right the examiner places
the web space of his
hand just superior to the
patella while applying
pressure or you can push
down on the patella directly
right and the patient
is going to be instructed
to gently uh contract
their quadriceps so that
quadriceps is going to
contract and you're going
to have pain with movements
of the patella or the
inability to complete the
test right and that's going
to give you an indication
that they have a
patellofemoral joint disorder.
Alright, so again, amazing job.
Very well done and I think
Maria, are you up again?
Alright, let's do all about me
for 300. All about me for 300.
A football player
presenting with pain on
this exam, especially
with rotation movement
will likely have an
injury to this structure.
And Maria, you just beat Cindy.
Sorry Cindy.
Maria, what's the answer?
What is the meniscus?
Medial meniscus or lateral
meniscus? That's 100
% right. Because what
you're doing here, you're
flexing the knee and
you're putting more
pressure on that meniscus.
And so, what was
that? How many points
for that that was
a 300 points and
we're going to
give that to Maria.
I think Maria might be
missing the patella. I did I
forgot to give Maria the
patella points right so
that is a very honest
observation thank you. So we're
going to give Maria 500
points and we're going to
give her another 300 points
for getting this question
right. Cindy your honesty
is very much appreciated
and I'm very well
done so Maria we got
the we have to score
correctly thank you
this is one of my favorite
tests to do if I'm on the
football sideline and a
football player can go off
the field and they're
complaining of knee pain and I
think there might be a
meniscus injury instead of
laying them down right away
I'm gonna have them just
hold on to the bench or hold
on to something and they're
gonna bend down turn the
knee side to side and if
have pain you're going to
be thinking about menaceous
injury right so again the
Thessaly's test very very
commonly used or at least
I commonly use it and
they're going to have pain
with the rotational component
all right so we have Maria
in the lead with 3700
and we are coming down to
the final question all right
so we're going to go with
Sherlock Holmes for 500.
A list of potential
conditions that could be
causing the patient's
symptoms that are considered
as you obtain a history
and a physical exam.
I'll give you a hint.
Make sure you have three
of these on your ******
note for full credit.
And Cindy just
beat Maria again.
So Cindy, what do you have?
What is differential diagnosis?
And that is correct for $500.
Very much needed. $500.
congratulations so that is
your differential diagnosis
right so when you guys are
going through your CSA
you always want to have at
least three different
differential diagnosis right
but in the field you might
have a couple you might have
four five six seven
there's a lot of different
pathology you always want
to think about what it could
potentially be that's why
we do the subjective that's
why we do the history taking
we find out the mechanism
of the injury and that's
why we do the physical
exam so we can't just end the
game in a tie but actually
I think maybe we can end
the game in a tie because
it was very well played
by both Maria and Cindy.
So out of the interest
of time I do appreciate
all everybody spending
their time with me
right I know we are a
few minutes over and I do
apologize but in the
interest of time we will
go through the Jeopardy
category separately.
I'm going to get rid of the pen
and the category would have
been if we had time the
category would have been DO
that do great work right and
then um so it would have
been an ICOM grad that
graduated in class of 1992
right um 1992 he was currently
served as the physician to
the president anybody know
who that is that is correct
I know you guys were thinking
about that whether you're
listening to the lecture
in the lecture hall or in
the library that is Kevin O
'Connor right and he's a
graduate from NYC comms 1992.
So people graduate and
they go on to do great
things so who's not to
say that you might be the
doctor to the president in
in a few years from now.
So to finish up the lectures,
quick summary slides,
history taken, physical
exam, come up with a
difference of diagnosis, know
the physical exam skills,
know what you're testing
for, and the subjective
objective finding, what's
normal, what's abnormal,
and then document
what you find. Always
document what you see,
document what you feel,
where the tenderness
is, range of version,
and special testing.
So once again,
thank you to Cindy
and Maria for joining us today.
Their help is greatly
appreciated. If you guys
have any feedback, please
leave feedback. We always
want to know how the lectures
are. So leave feedback,
let us know. Any
questions, reach out to me.
Here is the link to the
feedback form, which you
can get in your powerpoint
slides uh thank you all
for watching all right and
have a great day thank you
for having us thank you
maria and thank you cindy